O ne o
[Müzik]
bu Hoş geldiniz herhalde Ben
assolistleri kata çıktım ya
o torbaları Ben öyle Hepiniz hoş
geldiniz
güzel
organizasyonda beraber olmak benim için
çok büyük bir mutluluk kısımda bunları
öğrenci
zaten tekfurları zaman çağırsan buraya
geliyorum Her zaman ne isterseniz
kalorifer bakımı vesaire edecek
sıkıntılarımız olursa her türlü
betoloji ile ilgili sorularınız olursa
hava hakikaten bir çağrılar nereden uçak
uçak de korktum yani böyle bir salladı
ki ya ben bugün için önemli değil başlık
söyledim aslında
çok önemli gördüğüm şey izin sektörde ve
burada sizlerin ve daha sonra Bizi
buradan dinleyecek ve seyredecek olan
insanların hayatına ve dokunacağını
inandığım bir mesele çok önemli olduğunu
inandırıcı içerikle ilgili konuşmak
istiyorum uzaylı bu televizyonda
sinemada
oyuncu olarak öğretmen olarak yapımcı
olarak imza attı yani Geçenlerde Şöyle
düşündüm iyi üzerinde titreme yapmış
buyuz yani olay diye düşünüyoruz
oturuyorsunuz Böylelikle masasında 45
saat6saat makyajlar yapılmıştı Oldu
görüşürüz
1990'larda işte sizlerin seyrettiğiniz
ya da işte
bildiğiniz de ismiyle anlatan ibreti
kahve programında çok seviyormuşum ondan
sonra
bu kadar hızlı bir değişim sürecine
girdi ki bizim yaptığımız iş bizim
yaptığımız işler
Sen her zaman bunu görmeye başladım yani
seti o kadar çok büyüyor ya o kadar çok
değişiyor ki artık biz ile genişlemeye
başladık Çünkü ki takdir edersiniz şu
anda günümüzde İşte bu meşhur herkesin
söylediği dijital devrimin ardından
hepimiz birer canlı yayın aracı olduk
canlıyı televizyon oldu aslında şu anda
beni seyreden değerli misafirlerimizin
her biri birer televizyon kanalı ben de
işte O televizyon kanallarına şu
önerilerde bulunmak adına içeriği
öğrendi altlığı
aklıma takılan sizle paylaşmak
İstediğime yakın çevrenizde Mutlak
surette yararlanacağını düşündüm böyle
bir telefon hesaplamaların var Bunları
anlatmak istiyorum Şöyle ki şu anda
Yanılmıyorsam bizim sektörde çok
konuşulan hikaye çok ya bir iş
yapıyorsun Evet bir şey yapıyorum bu
salamı yapın ne yapıyorsun şu anda biz
de böyle bir ayrım var Ulusal dediğimiz
işte Haftanın yedi günü seyrettiğiniz
144/2 kalıp ortalama Bizler 140 dakika
yanlış söylüyorsunuz dünyada bu nadir
Başaran patladı de tek Başaran ülkemizi
847 kralını içerikler üretiyoruz Tabi
şimdi de çok oluşturuyorsunuz ay
dizilerde işte geliyorlar dakikalar ve
birbirlerine bakıyorlar yok klipler
şarkılar Mesela bir şeyde her şeyi bu
yani dünyalar kadar başarılması çok zor
bir iş 140 dakikaya genelde bize iki
ekip olarak çalışıyoruz ekiplerimizle
ortalamaya bir bize 200-150 kişiden
oluşuyor ve düşünün yani ortalama
200-220 tane bizi derslere üretiliyor
bunların fazla olanlarında pazara
çıkıyor Bir de şeyi dijital kısmı varmış
ithal eden birçok kanal şu anda tevekkül
etmiş durumda biliyorsunuz İşte en yakın
zamanda Disney plastik diye bir pilav
gelecek mi şu anda aklınıza gelen bu
gerekir bütün seyrettiler de Anlaşma
imzalamış bulunuyorlar ve nefis
söylememe gerek yok bildiği kiralaya
başlayayım dünyanın en büyük dijital
Platformu oldu ona işler Amazon HD Yoo
SMS ön bizim yerel bazda düşünecek
olursak bu blooky bir vesaire birçok işe
etsem bir de ayrılacağını uzak formu
şimdi bütün bunları niye anlatıyorum
bu Türkiye'de ve dünyada yani hepiniz
gözlemliyorsunuz dur çok ciddi bir içeri
sıkıntısı yaşanıyor artık anlatılacak
hikayeler bitti ve eski filmler yeniden
canlandırılıyor ya da işte böyle hayali
bir takım işler tasarlanıp ortaya Tabiri
caizse piyasaya sürülüyor Şunu
söyleyebilirim ben Mutlak surette şu
anda en değerli şey ben boş bir kağıt ve
kalem olduğunu görüyorum boş bir kağıt
bir kalem de yakalayacağız bir hikaye
ile dünyada yerinden oynatabilirsiniz
her gün sonra örneği işte beğenirsiniz
beğenmezsiniz eleştirisi zaman içinde
Bence çok güzel mesajlar olan verip bir
iş vardı su yüklemeye Bir 10-12 yıl
boyunca birilerini anlatmaya çalıştığı
satmaya çalıştığı yapmaya çalıştı o
projeyi bu işleri 21 sonra Yüz vermedi o
arkadaşımız Anadolu bir yolu buldu ve
dünyada Mesela en çok seyredilen
işlerden biri ol var bunun için
anlatıyorum yani ben Türkiye'nin her
zaman hikaye ve içerik Devleti olduğuna
inanıyorum Çelikler her şeyi bakarsınız
böyle işte Instagram'da ya da efendime
söyleyeyim
sosyal medya mecralarında içerik
üretecek bahsettiğim o değil bahsettiğim
ülkemizin hikâyeleri urların hikayesi
bir hikaye sizin yaşadığınız ailemizin
hikayesi Bunlar çok değerli Ben bunun
altını çizmek istiyorum mesela
etrafında
yapabiliriz diye ben izlediğimde yağışlı
oyunculuk yapmak istiyoruz sahneye
çıkmak istiyoruz tiyatro almak istiyorum
Hayır Lütfen bunu yapmayın bir sakin
olun bizim şu anda çok ciddi olarak
içeri ihtiyacımız yetiştiremiyoruz
yetişmiyor yetişmiyor
bütün öğrenci arkadaşlarımıza da
öğretmen arkadaşlarımıza Bu işle
ilgilenen ilgilenmeyen insanların
sermayesi en ucuz olan içerik üretmeye
öneriyorum altın içinde gerekiyor
aldığımız bir sayfa Bosch bu işte
laptopunuzu açacaksınız yaşadığınız bir
hikaye yaşadığınız bir olay ailenizin
başından geçen bir hikaye ile resimleri
aynı tutmak zorunda değilsiniz o sizin
böyle mutlu içerisinde sizin çok iyi bir
hayat olduğunuz bir şeyi Lütfen yazın
lütfen toplayın Lütfen bu Mutlak surette
kalite geçip Çünkü günümüzde bundan daha
değerli bir şey yok ya biz bunu o kadar
çok sıkıntısını yaşıyoruz ki herkes
oturduğu zaman olmaz kadar ürünlerine
anlatacağız Ne yapacağız şimdi
herkes böyle birbirine bakıyor ve birden
böyle işte parlak fikirlerini ihtiyaç
duyuyor bu anlamda bu dijitalleşme
süreciyle birlikte bizim karşımıza en
çok çıkan en çok sıkıntı yaşadınız
seversen arkadaşlar yani yapacak bir şey
yok yani her şeyi tekrar her şey
birbirinin aynı bu
mesela İşte en büyük kanalı TRT Deep
tarihi diziler yapıyor mu kız zaman
içinde çok böyle ederim bir mesele ya da
derin meseleler yok yani işte adresi
konuştu evleri işte Oo bağırması olduğu
bir
tekerleme gibi vesaire vesaire şekilde
mücadeleye şeklinde geliyor Biz şu anda
bunun çok sıkıntısını yaşıyoruz Eğer bu
bu gazete yer var mesela çok değerli
sonra da
internetten ulaşabilirsiniz gazetelerde
bir dönemde yayınlanan eski kadar
verdiğini tefrikaları çoğu hikaye olarak
yayınlanmış ama kitap olarak basılmamış
vs o tefrikaları ulaşabiliyor arkadaşlar
Bazı arkadaşlarımız bunların içerisinden
o kadar muhteşem işler bulabiliyorlar ki
Bense kaynakları öneriyorum yani hayatta
dururken yani İşiniz gücünüz yok değil
mi inanın çok keyifli bir şey doğru her
yerde bunu söylüyorum Çünkü ben
Türkiye'nin bu anlamda da
sadece bizi sektörlerden biraz
aldıkların arkasındayız ama yerli dizi
üretiminde ve pazarlamasında çok iyi bir
noktaya geliyoruz içeri kavramı da yavaş
yavaş insanların yüzü buraya dönmeye
başladı özellikle parmak izi diziler
Muhteşem Yüzyılda başlayan bir üst Kargo
ardından Şimdi mesela dizeye size
söyleyin çok keyiflidir 6 bölümü devam
edecek Atatürk Evet şu anda bizi
Atatürk'ün hayatından bir bölümü hani
böyle başlayacak bir şey 10 Kasımla
vefat edecek gibi değil Atatürk'ün
özellikle cumhuriyetin ilanına kadar
olan ki yaşam süreci ve mücadelesi işte
Trablusgarp
arkasından şey Balkanlar radosstar
onlardan çolakkaya bu süreç şahane bir
şekilde sitelerle uğraştığım Ama tabii
ki yıldır çalışıyor Bir saat yani bunlar
şunu göstermeye başladı İnsanların
kafası buraya da anlamda döndük zaten
Türkiye bir şekilde diyetleri bi şehri
olduğu için medeniyetlerin beşiği de
olduğu olduğu için sonra biz bu
içeriklerin çok bu büyük Meraklı çok
şükür
hasretini yaşıyoruz sizde lütfen
etrafınızda ya Çok ihtiyacımız var çünkü
İnanın şu çıldırmış gibi insanlar yani
şu anda böyle yepyeni bir hikaye var ona
bakıyorum Allah Allah mesela şeye dikkat
ettim özellikle artık şeye girmeye
başladılar Örneğin işleri Ben de kahve
diyebilirim belgesel var işte bir
döneminde mahkum edilmiş insanların
nasıl bir de davet içerisinde
cinayetleri işledikleri anlatılıyor
başka bir yerde işte 4'te görebiliriz
var o da gerçekliklerin hayatı
tariflerinden olmuş Park iş gerçek hayat
hikayeleri sinemalarda görüyorsunuz şu
anda müthiş bir biyografi meraklı olmaya
başladı işte Neden şimdi üstümü altımı
yolunu seyredelim de arkasından hemen
İşte bu sizlere gösterime giren
verdiğiniz hayatı insanların ilgisini
etmeye başladı şimdilerde aklınıza
gelecek bütün sanatçılar şu anda Yani
isimler bir burada hayatta olanların
biyografisi yapmaya çalışıyorum yavrum
bölüm yani tarafta olsun Süpersiniz Ama
acele etme biliyoruz ama çıldırmış gibi
insanlar şu anda topuklu işi maalesef
Ne oldu
Şu anda Kendi işimde ilgili olarak da
özellikle Memleketim Malatya ile ilgili
hikayelerini pişirdiği hikayeleri
araştırıyorum şu anda teşekkür edildi
tarihin
birçok ve Beşir yani çok medeniyetlere
ev sahipliği yapmış bir yer oradaki
ihtiyaçları peşine düşüyorum babamın
anlattığı dönemde topladığım şeyleri
yazmaya çizmeye çalışıyorum Çünkü yarın
öbür gün bunların yani derler ya bazı
zamanlar şurası topluyoruz işte babama
demişler şuradan bir tane olarak o Beyaz
Sayfalar hikayelerin değerli olduğuna
inanıyorum Ticaret değerinin ötesinde
sizi çok manevi olarak da mutlu
edecektir Yani şu anda belki
ki aklınıza bir şey gelmiyordu ama
Mutlak surette sizin hayatınızda size
dokunan senin yanından geçer sizlere Hoş
geldiniz vardır onları güzel bir
şeritler halinde fularını aradım
Arkadaşlarınıza bırakın ya da bize
ulaştırın çok mutlu da keyifli olur
dedikten sonra güzel bir şarkıyla
programı devam etmek istiyorum ineceğim
ben sonra kadar konuşmak zorunda
Çok
teşekkür ediyorum ben sizlere çok
[Müzik]
teşekkür ediyorum
çok keyifliydi içeriğin önemi şu anda
böyle karşınızda böyle Baba bağırıyor
Ben inanıyorum size de böyle bir yol
açmış olduğum bakalım gidiyoruz de Harry
potter'ı bir
beyaz kağıt ve bir kalemle yazdı
dünyanın en çok okunan en çok çizgi
filmlerinden biri oldu belki inanıyorum
böyle şeylerin çıkacağına Türkiye Çünkü
bu konuda birçok ülkeden daha fazla
avantajı teşekkür ediyorum dinlediğiniz
için Çok sağ olun Çok naziksiniz
yerleştir sağlam mı